[Music]
in sad times news submitted by big-time
baller the country is in mourning after
a gunman sprays bullets into a packed
music festival in Las Vegas so here are
the details the shooter has been
identified as Steven paddock 64 years
old he was found dead from my
self-inflicted gunshots he was on the
32nd floor of the Mandalay Bay shooting
into an open-air Music Festival called
route 91 Harvest Country Music Festival
around 10:00 p.m. last night so he's
responsible for the death of at least 58
people and about 515 people are also
injured during the shooting and the
stampede that followed how many boys did
he have that's crazy
500 people were affected they said that
they found ten guns yeah so this is now
the largest mass shooting in US history
there lasted about 15 minutes the
previous one was the pulse nightclub
massacre in Orlando that killed forty
nine yeah so was that the gay club yeah
I remember that one too yeah so it
appears as if he acted alone there is no
evidence of terrorism yet but early
reports did say that Isis claimed
responsibility for this but there's no
evidence of that yet
it's domestic terrorism mm-hmm so the
motive is still unclear but apparently
he had made recent gambling transactions
of 10,000 to 30,000 a day whoa he was
staying at the Mandalay Bay since
Thursday the shooting happened Sunday
night is that his normal type of
gambling or it was it like weird
behavior because some people are born
and 10 20 G's a day is like nothing well
it was recorded that he does have he'd
had money and that he is a gambler so
I'm not sure if that was like usually
what he would he would gamble with but
it is reported that he he'd so he lived
nearby and mesquite and he would drive
to Vegas all the time to go gambling
so that was like a common thing that he
would do I'm so hard well it's like I'm
gonna gamble have a good time and then
I'm gonna commit mass murder there's
actually a lot of odd things like for
one having ten rifles like if I were to
commit a mass shooting or whatever
instead of having ten rifles I'd
probably have one or two and really
stock up on just that one round so him
having ten it's like even and if you're
working alone that's a really really
weird thing in my opinion not only that
but so it is it almost sounds like
someone placed it on him he's not trying
to start any conspiracy theories or
anything like that but it just sounds
like like and the assailant had 12
knives on him it's like well you only
really need one yeah so it's kind of
weird maybe he doesn't he didn't
practice fast reload so then he has to
just shoot and then pick up another one
pick up another one Oh cuz like not
everyone can reload fast yeah so they
are reporting that authorities believe
that he had a device similar to a hammer
to smash the hotel windows in order for
him not to have access oh [ __ ] to the
outside and so they're saying that maids
did go into his room before and that
they didn't notice anything strange
he had previously purchased guns legally
but those were found in his home none of
the guns that he purchased legally were
so they're all illegal weapons that were
in his hotel it's in my knowledge I
don't know that yet they're just saying
that none of his legally purchased guns
were part of the tent she apparently had
a pilot's license too it was not up to
date that ATF is running urgent traces
on the guns that were found in the hotel
room they're reporting that he was a
retired accountant and he also made
money from renting and managing
apartment buildings that he owned in
Texas Nevada and Florida mm-hmm
this guy's really well put together then
on paper on paper yeah that's crazy
yeah I was reading about how he he was
like a small business owner or something
and his brother was just like yeah he he
really liked gambling so he decided to
move near there and it was from Florida
to Nevada yeah and I think he owns like
a small airplane or something or like
yeah we're like he's and he takes trips
to Alaska to go
hunting so he's not your average like
you know middle-class guy it sounds like
his quality of life is a little bit
above ours yeah yeah no children
divorced 27 years ago he had a
girlfriend living with him named Mary
Lou 62 years old so she initially was
one of the suspects that cops were
believing that was involved and this but
she was in the Philippines during the
school shootings they don't believe that
she's a suspect anymore
the neighbors and local police they said
that they they would never draw
attention to themselves it just sounded
funny cuz it was like like who would we
blame this on the wife she's in the
Philippines alright nevermind it's like
they're just try to jump to like the
next gape going immediately without even
considering where were you yesterday the
Philippines okay so his brother Eric was
interviewed he said that their family is
shocked and horrified that they would
never expect this from him he had plenty
of money he recently spoke to him to his
brother about their mother who lost
power during Hurricane Emma in Florida
that no one had seen him display any
strong religious or political beliefs so
we really don't know what the motive was
at all their father was a well-known
bank robber and was on FBI's most wanted
list from 1969 and 1977 he was diagnosed
as a psychopath and he died a few years
ago so that's some family history that's
crazy
Wow really trying to paint him as like
he's good he's crazy
yeah they're leading with the
Psychopaths part huh yeah the University
Medical Center um see of Southern Nevada
took in way more patients that they had
ever seen at one point they had eight
operating rooms operating at the time
and the entire night they had to do
damage control as like patients poured
in and they now have a really long line
of people at the hospital trying to
donate blood because that's the number
one thing that they're saying they need
the most right are soul guys you guys
are in near the area please go and
donate blood the White House press
secretary Sarah sand
responded I will show you what she said
in this video I'm about to show you
which the video includes a compilation
of iPhone footage from people that were
there so this morning it could be
distressing I'm already getting anxiety
I watched that [ __ ] all morning that is
crazy war is he saying where's that
[ __ ]
we can't go yet
our people falling because they got hit
or they just slip in like you think
normally happens in Vegas oh no and they
kept going even even after we lost it
just kept going and going
one man 29 year old Sonny Melton had
traveled from Tennessee to Las Vegas for
the concert with his wife Heather when
the bullets began raining down from
above Sonny shielded her from danger
selflessly giving up his life to save
hers they'd been married for just over a
year
others risked their own lives to save
people that they had never met Mike
McGarry a Philadelphia laid on top of
students at the concert to protect them
from the gunfire they're 23 2015 3 he
said and I've lived a good life pageant
her fiance Mike Jay fled for cover
during the attack and immediately
returned to the scene with their pickup
truck to help transport the wounded to
nearby hospitals Gail Davis who was
attending the concert with her husband
said she owes her life to a brave police
officer who instinctively she served as
a human shield protecting her from harm
sadly multiple police officers both on
duty and off duty were among those
killed or injured but what these people
did for each other says far more about
who we are as Americans than the
cowardly acts of a killer ever could and
then she goes on to that's like a so
tragedy man speaking Samoan she really
chokes up Wow
easy and they don't know what the motive
is that or anything huh so here's so he
was in the Mandalay Bay he was the best
of all another [ __ ] unfinished story
damn dude like just happen like we might
get more updates but if he's gonna I
mean if he if he's gonna kill himself he
should at least write a letter and leave
it in the room or like something like
it's so like maybe there is one but
not releasing it yet no they would have
said it this is the shooter that's the
best photo they could find yeah I said
the photo that's circulating everywhere
that's interesting
oh he broke a window right there yeah
two of them two windows yeah yeah like a
corner suite apparently that's what I
mean he's ballin so I could have two
vantage points yeah were there two
shooters why do you break - I don't know
maybe we might find out that there was
another shooter we don't know man it's
so odd because it's not it doesn't seem
racially motivated because it's white
people attacking white people that was
the instinctual thing and mean saying oh
like when I first heard of like Oh gun
man Las Vegas and country music
festivals like oh this is racially
charged but then when I found out the
gunman was white I was like okay this is
this is like a dead end kind of thing
yeah and I mean like what does he gain
from it you know like if he's a gambler
and you're pissed at the hotel cuz you
lost a lot of [ __ ] or whatever right
like I mean if that was me I would go at
the hotel the employees or whatever not
not just a random concert that has
nothing to do with the hotel that you're
staying in but then it would have to be
premeditated right if he got all those
guns
yeah yeah he thought this out because he
the concert was like a weekend event
yeah he targeted the week the festival
Trump a president Trump he tweeted my
warmest condolences and sympathies to
the victims and families of the terrible
Las Vegas shooting god bless you all
he also he did a statement on TV as well
his statement was ridiculous it was kind
of comical like you like what happened
is really sad but I can't take that full
serious like why not just a speech
pattern like because I don't know no you
could say the most serious things but
because it's Trump saying it it's like
difficult to take it serious there was
like an estimated 22,000 people at this
concert and it took police about an hour
to locate where the shooter was coming
from oh yeah yeah yeah yeah hey I mean
mastered and so you really did it right
because he picked a venue it picked a
time when there was a lot of people
concentrated in one area where there was
no you know actual exit to this area
because it because people trampling over
people you know once they figure out
like what's happening and then he has a
really high vantage point and he also
got guns that didn't use the guns that
he legally obtained Hughes I guess what
they're reporting now is that as
illegally obtained weapons and it's
really hard to even get automatic
weapons to begin with so I don't even
know how he got them but yeah automatic
weapons which is you need like a high
level license for that like I even
though Las Vegas is a state where you
can own fully auto legally you have you
have to have like like a you have to own
a you know gun shop or whatever like do
you have to have certain levels even if
you own it I think it's still very very
difficult so you heat a Hugh had to
steal it or whatever because you it's
not easy to have that and to move it
into the hotel room like that true yeah
I mean he could have put it into pieces
and like put it but it's it's I think a
lot of people that don't understand how
the gun laws work what he already has in
his possession is illegal that that that
shouldn't exist technically and I don't
know how he got it because what he has
you know not normal people just can't go
into the gun store and buy that yeah I
guess it isn't happening a lot of people
were just starting to like anti-gun
there since I got done that but the
House the White House press secretary
Sarah Sanders a woman you guys just saw
in the video she said today is not the
time to discuss about gun control policy
today's for consoling the survivors and
it's a time reunite that's what Hillary
did though she was like not to get
political or anything but now is the
time to stand up to the NRA
the Primmer says is not the time to get
political but let's get political right
now I don't know I feel like I see both
sides where it's like yeah you got to
use people's you know shock and and
people realizing the crazy of what you
know guns can do to jump on it but also
it's people that don't understand
anything about gun laws that pretty just
you know like it they're not making
informed decisions like what that killer
used is already illegal a completely
illegal normal people are instead of
talking about guns it should be more
about mental health I agree
how can we like have you know access
like everyone have access to you know
usual checkups and regular check-ups and
to just really take care of their minds
yeah cuz the way I see like mental
health is like is like like you get a
cold you know if you if you get some
anxiety or whatever like it's it should
be treated like it's fine everyone gets
it everyone gets depression from time to
time but the way it's stigma it's so
stigmatized that like if you get it
people start looking at you as like oh
you can't handle yourself you're not
positive enough you're sick yeah yeah I
don't want to be around negative people
or like you know all those things I
think it's it's very it's it's really
bad in our culture we don't really help
that that's probably why his brother in
his interview was like he never showed
any signs
he's probably suppressing the [ __ ] out
of himself so he keeps up like looking
positive and core who knows you know
well I wasn't there like reading reports
saying that there was a lady like 45
minutes in the incident happening yeah
maybe screaming at the crowds that she
made her way to the to the front row and
started telling everyone you are you're
all going to [ __ ] die 45 minutes
before yeah it was like oh you had to be
ass coordinated the old saying that
right like yeah well they think a lady I
don't know lady push your way through
and so crazy it's tough so scary like
when I first heard it this morning
my immediate instinct was to start
carrying
rifle - just in case yeah you just have
it it's like on you all day long yeah
you just want to survive you know you'd
say yeah yeah it's like a misdemeanor or
felony or whatever but you better to be
alive then then you like the worst that
kind of at that point though you can't
even shoot back you can yeah you can't
if you see that hole like I wouldn't
want to shoot at the hotel cuz I might
hurt someone anything true I knew was
really dark to see it was even harder to
see mm-hmm there's no way you would have
seen in there it's a hard thing in
combat because yet there's there's
there's the sight of we need all get
arms and we need to protect ourselves
but like how do you how do you protect
yourself when you're in that moment you
know you don't even have time to assess
the situation you're going to start you
know it's like it's not a rule I think
we're also looking at it from from
someone that's on the ground floor you
know but what if you're like the shooter
in the hole in the like you know hotel
Oh like you hear a bad back oh [ __ ] I'm
hearing some [ __ ] call 9 on one but you
can't kick the door down if I stop
immediately put your weapon down and you
don't find our shot but if you're able
to stop them get on the floor
you call 9-1-1 that's true some you know
what I mean like you have more options I
feel like well rest in peace yeah thanks
for watching guys and those are our
thoughts what are your thoughts don't
forget to comment below we want to know
what you guys are thinking but don't
write anything that will make it sad or
make us mad because after all we're just
kidding news and we're a very happy
channel for the last video click up here
[Music]